and key drivers of health care costs
be sure to watch c-span's washington
journal live at 7 eastern saturday
morning
join the discussion
[Music]
next supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg reflects on her life and career
while discussing her latest book my own
words which is a collection of her
writings and speeches dating back to the
eighth grade she was joined at the event
by contributors of the book and court of
appeals judge robert katzman who
moderated the discussion
from georgetown university this is just
under an hour and a half
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone and welcome it's
a pleasure to be here with all of you
as our spring semester draws to a close
for our marver h bernstein symposium
and i wish to begin by expressing our
deepest appreciation to justice ruth
bader ginsburg for joining us here on
campus today it's an honor to welcome
her to gaston hall and to hear
reflections this afternoon
and i also wish to express our gratitude
to the honorable robert katzman chief
judge for the u.s court of appeals for
the second circuit
for all his efforts to make this
extraordinary symposium possible for our
community
i look forward to sharing a few more
words about judge katzman in just a
moment
i'd also like to thank professor mary
hartnett and professor wendy williams
from our georgetown law center
who will join justice ginsburg in
conversation today
professor hartnett and professor
williams are justice ginsburg's
authorized biographers
and co-authors of her recent book
my own words published this past year
finally i wish to thank all of you for
being here today for this very special
gathering
the bernstein symposium was created
under the memory
of marver and shava bernstein dr marver
bernstein whose work in the areas of
regulation
personnel and administrative reform
continues to influence scholars today
he served as the founding dean of the
woodrow wilson school of public and
international affairs at princeton
as president of brandeis
and for the last seven years of his life
as a professor of politics and
philosophy here at our school of foreign
service
we're deeply grateful to michael and
susan gellman
and all those who have generously
supported this symposium and enabled us
to bring such esteemed guests to campus
including vice president al gore
journalist tim russert senator patrick
leahy and justices sonia sotomayor and
stephen breyer to take part in this
forum which honors
dr bernstein's many contributions to our
university community and to our
understanding of the us political system
today we have the privilege of welcoming
ruth bader ginsburg associate justice of
the supreme court of the united states
since her confirmation to the court
nearly 25 years ago
she's brought a thoughtful measured
approach to her distinguished service on
the bench
building consensus
and voicing eloquence and dissent
we're deeply honored to have her with us
this afternoon to share her in her
insights and reflections with our
georgetown community
to introduce justice ginsburg it's my
pleasure to welcome chief judge robert
katzman of the u.s court of appeals for
the second circuit judge kathman was
appointed to the federal bench in 1999
by president clinton and he began his
service as chief judge 14 years later in
2013.
like his mentor in this symposium's
namesake marva bernstein
judge katzman is also an engaged member
of our georgetown community having
taught at the walsh as the walsh
professor of government and as professor
of law and public policy
he currently serves on the board of
visitors of our law center and is also
one of the founders of this symposium
before his appointment to the second
circuit he was a fellow of the
governmental studies program of the
brookings institution and served as
president of the governance institute
in 2001 he received the charles e
merriam award from the american
political science association in 2003 he
was named the fellow of the american
academy of arts and sciences
and in 2011 received the chesterfield
smith award from the pro bono institute
in recognition of his outstanding
dedication to pro bono work
including programs regarding immigration
this award was presented to him by
justice ginsburg who engaged his
guidance and expertise when he served as
special counsel pro bono to senator
daniel patrick moynihan and then judge
ginsburg during her confirmation process
to the supreme court supreme court
bob it is wonderful to welcome you back
to campus this afternoon i want to thank
you again for your leadership your
generosity and your sustained commitment
to our community ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming the
honorable robert katzman
it's great to be back
thank you president de joya for your
generous introduction
for elevating our proceedings with your
presence and i might add for your
efforts to promote
understanding on some very difficult
issues that confront
our society
it was marva bernstein's idea that
georgetown should create a position that
would bridge the campuses between the
law center downtown and the main campus
and he worked with the law center to
make that a reality
as a beneficiary of that effort i will
always be grateful to him
the bernstein symposium brings the
campuses together
and our program this afternoon draws
upon the talents of the main campus and
the georgetown law center faculty
i know that
my friend bill trainor dean of the law
school regrets being out of town today
and we appreciate his participation in
previous years
this symposium series is very dear to me
and i'm very grateful to still be part
of it and grateful to the government
department and its distinguished chair
charles king
for all of his wise counsel
i i am also very grateful to all those
friends of marver bernstein who made
this symposium possible including the
gelmans who
president de joya mentioned
now this is for me this afternoon a
particularly special occasion
for several reasons
music has always been important to me as
it is for so many people
what else but music can give a person a
sensation both soothing and inspiring
a transporting experience and have rich
associations in its wake in the memory
be it the notes of verde or beyonce
stephen sondheim or philip glass
there's some music out there that speaks
to each of us
something universal
so it is a distinct thrill for me to
introduce as our bernstein honoree
someone who demonstrably understands
something about universal values
and someone who in fact
has performed twice
on the opera stage with a washington
national opera
at the kennedy center
no less
a washington post story recently praised
our guest for not only her performance
but for her writing as well and i quote
her timing delivery and material which
she wrote herself
were all even more polished and hit
every mark
the headline observed before adoring
crowds
justice prevails
[Music]
justice writing superb delivery
i think you know where i'm headed here
the post story was indeed not about the
reaction to justice ginsburg's reading
of a consequential opinion from the
supreme court bench
or the reaction to one of her
well-crafted speeches to a university or
a bar group
no the washington post story really was
a review of justice ginsburg already
acknowledged as a veritable rock star in
the story as also
and i quote an actual opera star
wrote and the jet
on thursday night march 9th the kennedy
center opera house was filled with an
adoring crowd
that roared with adulation for her at
every opportunity
ginsburg rules washington national opera
another washington post headline read
justice ginsburg is
of course also a supreme court justice a
national icon
the subject of books
pop art t-shirts
and i understand soon a movie starring
natalie portman
it's true
why is why is in why is this in fact so
in part justice ginsburg is celebrated
for her impact
as a judge on this country's highest
court the second woman ever on the court
for her path marking
contributions to the law's developments
for her methodical brilliant analyses
and concise elegant prose
in part no doubt it is because of her
trailblazing role before becoming a
judge as a lawyer's advocate on behalf
of women's rights
but i think it is also because the
american public admires her character
her values and feel a connection with
her and i witness that connection first
hand as president de joya noted in the
con in the course of her confirmation
journey
in the summer of 1993
when she was first thrust into national
celebrity when i accompanied her on
capitol hill
at the invitation of her senate sponsor
daniel patrick moynihan an experience
that i will always cherish
for me the most telling moment of that
confirmation hearing came in response to
a question from senator cole
of wisconsin
and he asked her
how
would she want the american people to
think of her
and
ruth bader ginsburg replied quietly
i would like to be thought of
as a person who cares about people
and does the best she can
with the talent she has to make a
contribution to a better world
that i think captures justice ginsburg's
essence
she is a person with seemingly limitless
capacity for friendship and kindness
in ways large and small
no matter the weighty burdens of her
daily life
she is a friend for the chilly winters
of life someone who places others before
her own convenience as i have observed
someone of conviction and determination
a person with a true sense of the
aesthetic
taken by the simple
pleasures of life has to offer be it a
beloved arya or a horse back ride
and to know her family
her incomparable
partner marty
and her accomplished children and indeed
her entire family is to have a sense of
what for her or life's blessings
and makes each of us appreciate what is
truly important justice ginsburg is
someone of grace
prodigious work habits good humor
dignity and style
so in justice ginsburg the public
observes someone for whom the law
is not about abstractions her life in
the law has been and continues to be
about working to ensure
that each of us can realize his or her
potential
for her life can entail the most
difficult of challenges both
professional and personal
but she has always been determined to
meet them to struggle through the
obstacles to secure a better future
for those of us here now and those
who follow
so that enduring connection that she
established with the american people who
watched the confirmation hearings
was based on their perception
that in this age
too often gripped by glitz and
self-promotion
ruth bader ginsburg was someone whose
virtues were in are very real
and early on i could sense that
connection
as persons of all ages approached her
for an autograph and she agreed with
friendliness
i think it's actually
very affirming of our country and of
ourselves that this intellectual
powerhouse woman
draws huge crowds and is a fixture
extolled in pop culture
the occasion of our marver bernstein
program is the recent publication of my
own work
which is a collection of justice
ginsburg's writings it's a great read
and i can't recommend it enough indeed
everybody here will get a copy
the book has been wildly heralded in
book reviews
as a collection of thoughtful writing
about perseverance and community and the
law
reflecting an abiding commitment to
protect outsiders and others
as a core american value
as a tonic to the current national
discourse showcasing the justice's
astonishing intellectual range
from law and lawyers
in opera to tributes to lewis brandeis
william rehnquist and gloria steinem
paying tributes to those who came before
her and others who work with her
as writing my own words is a model for
all of us precise varied
beautiful structured
like a wonderful piece of music
joining me in conversation now
are
justice ginsburg and her two colleagues
on the project mary hartnett an adjunct
professor at georgetown law who focuses
on international women's rights
and wendy williams professor law emerita
at georgetown law best known for her
work on the subjects of gender and law
please join me now as we welcome justice
ginsburg and her colleagues on stage for
a conversation
[Applause]
i've never heard such applause that's uh
in a university institution that's
really uh extraordinary just uh
justice ginsburg if i if i might begin
why this book of writings and and why
now
the original plan
bob was
that
wendy and mary would write
a biography my authorized biography
you two started was it the year 2004
when you came to me yeah they came to me
and said
someone is going to write about you
so you might as well designate people
you trust
and we we volunteer so
the the idea was
that they would write the biography and
then as a supplement
we would have a collection
of my writings
2004 became 2010 and
so i suggested why not flip the order
do the book of writings first
and then by the biography
and you two were very enthusiastic about
that idea so was your publisher
[Laughter]
and someday
someday maybe they can tell you when
the biography will appear
well it's such a best seller as it is
you know it's it'll be some lead on lead
time before the book is actually
published so
no pressure on it so tell tell us wendy
and and mary uh
about the process of gathering and
choosing
the materials to be published sure maybe
i'll start um but first the the
forthcoming biography we can't publish
yet because justice ginsburg keeps doing
amazing things and we need to cover them
[Applause]
all but selecting the materials was a
lot of fun but i have to tell you it
wasn't easy and here's why justice
ginsburg is an
extraordinarily prolific writer and
speaker
and not just as a supreme court justice
not just as a judge not just as a law
professor or a litigator for the first
piece in the collection we actually went
back over 70 years
to a piece that justice ginsburg wrote
when she was in eighth grade
it probably won't surprise you to know
she was the editor of her school
newspaper
in public school in brooklyn the name of
the paper was the highway
herald and the piece that is the first
piece in this book
she wrote again when she was in eighth
grade the other items in the school
newspaper talked about the circus the
school play
but young ruth wrote about the ten
commandments
the magna carta
the bill of rights
the declaration of independence and the
united nations charter which had just
been
adopted
so
[Applause]
so you can understand the enormity of
trying to select just enough to fill a
book as opposed to gaston hall and so
wendy and i met with justice ginsburg
and kind of got a big picture of the
shape we thought we wanted the book to
be in and then wendy and i exchanged 28
drafts of an outline
and then the
great thing about working with justice
ginsberg is she has a phenomenal memory
so
we would talk about a particular speech
and she would say we might want to
consider
the version i gave in paris in 2008
where i talked about brownview board of
education
and so we did and and justice ginsburg
has an amazing staff led by kim mckenzie
who would then go actually find that
piece so we were aided in that the other
fun part about selecting the pieces is
we also needed to select photographs and
so justice ginsburg when she was
speaking at georgetown law last year
came in advance of her speech into my
office which is literally wallpapered
with pictures of justice ginsburg
at every stage of her life and of marty
and her family and so we had a fun time
with dean traynor
picking out different photos for the
book and then finally the last part was
writing introductory material and
justice ginsburg wrote a beautiful
introduction to the book and then wendy
and i
had a challenge in that writing and
introduction to each section we couldn't
just put in the whole chapters we've
already written for the forthcoming
biography we had to winnow out just a
few of the key parts
and leave something for the future so we
did that then wendy did you want to oh
just a few words um first of all i just
have to do a shout out to mary because
she keeps me on track and on time which
is
as anybody who knows me knows is an
incredible job
and she and she has been the go-between
um among the three of us making sure
that we all produce and when we are
going to produce and
what we want to do and telling us there
are certain things that can't go in the
book because
we have a page limit so so that's what i
lived through and it was a stressful
extremely stressful but it was also
wonderful um and i think it's fair to
say
that one of our goals consistent with
what we know of the justice
was um
was that we would
make it accessible
not just to lawyers in the legal
profession
but um
to the general public as well
and i hope we achieve that goal you you
will be the judge of that because you
all have the book soon and you can let
us know whether you think we did it
right or not
and of course the main job was to
capture the essence of the justice's
style which is unique and her substance
which is a remarkable
performance and somehow boil it down
uh to
its essence
and present it uh in a book
um
so
i i want to say
[Music]
our efforts
i just can't help myself i have to throw
this in our efforts include not just her
own words
but
but a couple other little tidbits as
well
and one of them well you already know
that she's a she loves the opera right
she she starred in an opera will not
quite start but
and and the problem is
she can't sing very well
so
she said if she could she'd be a diva
but as it was she has a pretty good job
uh as a supreme court justice
so
one of the things we include in it
included in the book
is um is an excerpt from an opera
and some of you may have heard of it
it's called scalia ginsburg
and you get a little taste of
of
an opera about the supreme court and
these two justices
in this book
and the second thing um
i'm especially
fond of here is
there are two
two well excerpts really from two
speeches in honor of the justice
by a splendid guy ruth ginsburg calls
her life partner
um
the late great tax lawyer and law
professor at georgetown martin ginsberg
known tall as marty
so i think you'll find things in there
that are
attuned to who she is
but by some others
and at the core of it is our effort
together to
present you with the essence of what she
believes and how she operates and how
she thinks
and what she has contributed so
that's it
justice ginsburg uh
before you are on the supreme court you
of course litigated
in front of the supreme court in the
1970s you were head litigator
in the women's rights project of the
aclu
you took part in 34 cases before the
supreme court
as either lead litigator or co-litigator
you won five out of six cases you argued
there can you talk a little bit about
how you developed your legal strategy
in those not so good old days the legal
strategy
was clear
the first was to convince judges that
there was such a thing as gender-based
discrimination
and by the 70s i think
juris well appreciated
that race discrimination was odious
but they tended to think of differential
treatment
of women as operating benignly
in women's favor
so the supreme court never saw a gender
discrimination case
that regarded as anything but
favor to the woman so go back to
is bradwell the illinois
1872 or 73 but anyway this
woman 73
qualified to be a member of the illinois
illinois
state bar in all respects but one the
one she was a woman
and the court could rationalize that by
saying well unpleasant things sometimes
go on in courtrooms and the lady
wouldn't want to be
present
or on the next one
uh we can take dassard against cleary by
the way that will be reenacted at the
supreme court on monday
this is a 1948 case
the michigan supreme court
passed
the michigan legislature
passed a law that said
women may not attend bar
unless
they are
the wife or the daughter
of the male bar owner
when that came to the supreme court the
opinion is rather glib
but it does talk about
unseemly things going on at taverns and
saloons best to keep the dainty little
woman out
or even later in 1961
it was a case of gwendolyn hoyt who
stood trial for the murder of her
flandering abusive husband
there were no women on florida juries
[Music]
and the supreme court saw that
as a favor to women
women after all were the center of home
and family life therefore they should
not be distracted by being called away
from the home for jury duty
so the objective was to
let the court understand
that these classifications far from
favoring women
kept her
as justice brennan
said in some time in the 1970s
not on a pedestal
but in a cage
now that was the job first to persuade
the triers that there was such a thing
as gender-based discrimination
and then the the laws that were our
immediate target
were laws that
wendy williams described so well as
as
creating separate fears for people
so there was the woman who took care of
the home and the children
and the man
who took care of the family's economic
well-being
and many many laws were
more written with that picture of how
life should be organized
in mind
so
the effort was to say
there's something wrong with that
picture of the world
there are many women
were not particularly
um
good at the home job but maybe very good
as firefighter or police
all those
were off limits to women at the time and
there are many men who genuinely care
for children
so the law should speak about parents
rather than mother or father
the object was to
break down
all those explicit gender-based
distinction so that people could be
as
with ma
mara thomas
expressed it people would be free to be
you and me whatever your god-given
talents you could pursue it
and your
being male or female should not hold you
back
so
one day maybe you would like to
to add to that because in the 70s wendy
was a principal litigator for an
organization
in based in san francisco called equal
rights advocates still in existence and
going strong
well it was an amazing
10 years
really nine years i guess
that ruth ginsburg led
the burgeoning women's legal movement in
this country
and part of her strategy was she used to
she
she taught law on top of being this
supreme court litigator
and she was very focused on
teaching
schooling
the justices rather than
attacking them or
bullying them in any way
and she did it brilliantly
she at one point um
i i guess actually in in the very early
cases tried to get the court
to understand that while
race discrimination and sex
discrimination are by no means identical
phenomena
they both need to be closely scrutinized
by courts
to
ensure equal protection of the laws for
women
and
for people of color
so
so she tried to get the court to do that
and characteristically
i would say
when
the supreme court didn't quite bring
itself to do that
she picked a middle
approach
and brought them along
and then in the end she went on the
supreme court and got to write
an opinion that pulled that all together
for all time called frontiero versus
richardson
but let me if i if i might um
ask you about
your views about a dissents there's a
very
thoughtful
reading in the in the book
about
the role of dissents
you discuss the importance of respecting
an opponent's view
even when publicly disagreeing
as you exhibited for example and shelby
versus holder
the voting rights act case
you talk about
dissents and how justice brandeis would
sometimes
write a dissent and then not
not publish it there's a whole book of
of uh his unpublished ascents
could you give us a sense justice
ginsburg of uh your philosophy of
dissents when you write a dissent how
you think about the sense
i had great
role models in that respect brandeis and
holmes i think it was holmes who said
if i descended in every case where i
thought the court got it wrong no one
would read my descents
so i'm going to save them
for the ones that
really matter
i keep on my desk the
unpublished opinions of mr justice
brandeis these were opinions that
that brandeis had labored over
but then in the end he thought what the
court had done
wouldn't do any harm
so
he would bury it it would become a
graveyard
descent
so
his view was that
his voice would be
all the
more compelling
if he has been to his descent
for when it
really mattered and cardozo was the same
kind of justice
the great law professor paul foreign who
clerked for brandeis
remarked that this
then knew justice cardozo
very often
when it came down to the
published opinion
suppressed his vote at conference
many times he voted one way at the
conference but then joined the court's
opinion
going the other way
always
on the view that what the court
was doing
would do no harm
it was okay
and so i i do not take every opportunity
to dissent i do try to save them
for when it when it counts when it
when it really matters
could i jump in for one second
absolutely another example of justice
ginsburg's generosity with her time is i
taught a course this semester on the
role of dissenting opinions and we had a
surprise guest lecturer one evening
and i thought justice ginsburg's
security detail was going to have to
administer cpr to at least half of the
students
justice
thank you
again for doing that
in your in your in your book you include
your rose garden
acceptance speech
i remember well in your senate
confirmation hearing opening statement
looking back what what stands out to you
about the nomination confirmation
experience one vivid memory is of a very
bright
then young man
who was my guide he was appointed by
senator daniel patrick moynihan
to take me around the halls of
of
the congressional office buildings and
bob
we would be walking to a particular
senator's
office and
and bob would say this is what he's
interested in
and
it would be wise not to talk about this
that and the other thing
to this
this gentleman and that was the
honorable robert
katzman
what i remember
was the collegiality the civility of
those
those hearings that entire process
i was nominated on june
14
1993
and i was confirmed
on august 3rd
there was a truly bipartisan spirit in
the
congress
my biggest supporter on the judiciary
committee was orrin hatch
the vote was 96 to 3.
and never mind that i had been on the
board of the aclu and co-founder of the
women's rights project
and one of four general counsel to the
aclu
not a single question was asked about my
aclu connection
for justice breyer who came one year
after
it was pretty much the same
a collegial atmosphere
watching the most recent confirmations i
wish
there was a way that we could
wave a magic wand and get back to the
way it was in the way
the way it should be
we can only hope
we can only hope
but i i what i remember about some
things about that process is that the
white house
uh brings in uh experts
to talk to the nominee and uh
ruth bader ginsburg knew more about each
subject than the experts
and it was it was a
it was really i think a very humbling
experience for uh
all those coming in
that was really the best week for me
because i could choose
any law professor i respected
to bring me
up to speed in various areas of the law
and i
realized how popular
ruth ginsburg was
not just
when
people would come up to her
and ask for an autograph but
the senators across parties all wanted a
photo opportunity
so we would we would go in um to talk to
a senator and it became clear
that
what the senator really wanted was a
picture to send back
and i also remember very fondly
senator grassley
there was a
a group from iowa that
was putting on some ice cream
demonstration
in the capitol and he said to uh
then judge ginsburg
would you mind
coming with me uh to this ice cream
demonstration and we went
and it was you know
a different time
than than we have now um
yeah it was the dairy farmers
the dairy farmers right exactly exactly
it wasn't
most spectacular selection of ice cream
in every flavor
it was delicious
delicious i remember
you have a a a new colleague as of a
couple of weeks ago
[Music]
how does the core change
when the composition
changes
every time we have a new justice we have
a new court
and that means we will get a photograph
of the new court which i will give
to my lockers when we
have it done
i think the the person who is happiest
to welcome a new justice is the
departing junior justice
which is
now justice kagan no longer junior
justice the junior justice has the job
of
opening the door if anyone knocks during
a conference
answering the telephone
but most daunting at all
of all staying after we leave and giving
all of our decisions
what cases did we grant review and
different whatever actions we took at
conference
she relays those to the entourage from
the clerk's office the legal office
and then junior justice
of late has had one more assignment the
junior justice serves on the
committee
so
that was an uphill battle for justice
kagan but she did succeed in getting a
frozen yogurt machine
[Music]
there's musical chairs and our seats
change everything is done by seniority
at the court
so and and you asked about change when a
new justice
comes on board i think the biggest
change
in the 24 years i've been there is when
justice o'connor
retired
there have been other changes but not
of the consequence of
justice ocon is leaving us
just from a personal
point of view
where there were two of us and we didn't
look alike and didn't talk alike
but when justice okada left
there were these
eight
most of them rather well-fed men
and then there was this small little
woman so the picture was all together
wrong
it's true now with three of us we're
spread all over
the bench
and that's
much better it was lonely when it's so
color left
much better
let me ask you uh justice ginsburg most
most of the
people in our audience today are college
students
when you were in college
in the 1950s
which classes and
professors
had had the biggest impact on you
well i've talked about my european
literature professor vladimir bolkhov
who
literally changed the way i read and the
way i write he was a magnificent teacher
but listening to what you said
about when you made that
extraordinarily fine introduction
two
courses that i took at cornell
university
that have stayed with me and enriched my
life
music 101 and 102
and fine arts 101
and 102.
so for any of you who are college
students i would recommend whatever
whatever is your main
interest
do take courses in music and art
i agree
uh you you've made a lot of great
decisions in your life and uh this this
goes back to something that wendy had
mentioned
surely a great decision was to to
to marry
marty ginsberg could you tell us
something about that momentous decision
and marty and i met when
he was 18 i was 17. he was in his second
year i was in my first year at cornell
he had a girlfriend at smith i had a
boyfriend next columbia law school
but
there's a long week off in a cold week
and it's going to need off in between
weekends
so
these friends thought it would be that
marty and i would probably like each
other i could go to the movies with him
or to the college spa and so that's how
we started as as just friends
and then when marty gave up
his chemistry major because it
interfered with golf practice
he became
fairness he was on the golf team yes he
was he
then switched to government and he would
ask what courses are you taking and then
he would sign up for
the same
the same
courses somewhere along the way i
realized that
marty was the first boy
probably the only boy i had ever known
who cared that i had a brain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a friend of mine
a college classmate
said ruth you are fantastically
because marty is so secure about himself
that he will never regard you as any
kind of
a competitor any kind of a
threat
and marty for all the 56 years we spent
together
he was always my biggest booster
when he went my first year of law school
marty was bragging to his classmates
that his wife was going to be on the
lower view in those days law review was
strictly on the basis of grades no
writing competition
and the only woman on the lower view at
that time she said i looked at you you
were this little twerp
and
your husband is bragging about you and
of course i did make the
law of you
and
as i said marty was my
my biggest booster and
another
great thing about him
is he
he said
he learned early
on from
two women that it would be good for him
to develop skills in the kitchen
and he said those two women were his
mother
and his wife
well i think
it wasn't fair what he said about his
mother but it certainly was about what
we had an arrangement where
i would do the everyday cooking and
marty would be the weekend and the
company cooked i was never allowed to
cook for guests
and my daughter around her
early high school years noticed this
enormous difference between daddy's
cooking and mommy
[Music]
and decided
that mommy should be phased
out of the
so marty became
the only chef in our family and when i
moved to the supreme court and
the spouses met
quarterly for lunch
and they shared catering
responsibilities marty was always the
number one pick
do the lunch
there is in fact a book that you can
you can get at the supreme court's gift
shop it's called
supreme chef and supreme chef is marty
it's a collection of his
recipes
it was inspired by martha analito
who is also a very good cook and
and she when marty died she thought the
best tribute
there could be to him was to have
a cookbook of his
his recipes
the thing about him is that he was so
remarkable in so many ways
if you just thought about him
as a tax lawyer
or as a professor
of tax
he would he would be
extraordinarily distinguished
in those ways
but all these other talents golf uh uh
chef and he really was uh
a unique person and it was a real
privilege to be his
to be his friend and to be his
his colleague you include um some
wonderful writings by by marty do you
have a favorite
there's a great introduction of me that
[Music]
one of those is is in marty's own words
right in in the audio book
is it yes
introduction fellowship programs
anniversary at georgetown we had a tape
of that
but the other was a speech that marty
had written and wasn't planning to give
to the 10th circuit judicial conference
in the summer of
2010
when he died in june that year
but his speech was
already
written out
so i went to the 10th circuit
and i read
marty's speech
i didn't have quite the timing that he
would have had but it was
it was
okay and that talk
is the basis
for this
film
and that will be in progress i think in
august they'll begin filming
is that the natalie portman
yeah
so one last question before we turn it
over to this the audience
um
and that is uh as as uh wendy and mary
have pointed out um
in the in this in the book there are
excerpts from the opera scalia
ginsburg um
and uh we've we've
had excerpts from it at our second
circuit conference um
there have been full performances um
in this in in i know in in virginia and
in glimmer glass
glasses this summer glimmer glasses this
summer it's august 4th and 13th august
4th and 13th
can you tell us something about your
decision to include those excerpts
say something about the opera anything
you like about your relationship with
justice scalia before we turn it over to
the students
the opera was written by derek wein
who was a music major at harvard and has
a master's in music from yale
and then decided that it would be
it would be helpful to to know a little
bit about the law so he enrolled in his
hometown law school
at university of maryland law school
and when he was in a constitutional law
class
he was reading these sometimes dueling
opinions
scalia for the court ginsburg and
descent ginsburg for the court scalia in
descent
and decided that this could make
a very funny opera
and in addition would convey a little
bit about
about the law
so to give you the flavor of it
it opens with justice scalia's
rage aria which is very handling in
style
and it goes this way
the justices are blind
how can they possibly spout this
the constitution says
absolutely
nothing about this
so that sets up just scalia and then i
answer him
i tell him that he's seeking brightline
solutions to problems that don't have
easy
answers but the great thing about our
constitution
[Music]
is that like our society
it can evolve
so that's that's that's
sets it up
the plot is roughly based on mozart's
magic flute
and justice scalia has to go through a
certain number of trials
he has been locked up in a dark room
being punished for excessive dissenting
and then i enter through a glass ceiling
[Music]
i entered to help him get through these
trials
and the
commendatory who was borrowed from don
giovanni
asked me how
can you come to his assistance he is
your enemy
and i said no he's not my enemy he's my
friend
and that's
really the
the theme of the opera how two people
who think differently about some very
important things can nonetheless
genuinely
like each other enjoy each other's
company
one of the things that justice scalia
would do
every now and then
he'd read one of my opinions
whether he agreed with it or not he'd
call
to correct my grammatical errors
never sent this through the channels and
never on paper but always in a telephone
call
my
typical of justice scalia was
we
disagreed
sharply in the virginia military
institute case the question whether
virginia could maintain a facility that
offered great advantages but that was
closed
to
to women
we went back and forth it was like a
ping pong game many times
sclera came to my chambers one day and
threw down a sheaf and paper and said
ruth this is my pen ultimate draft of my
descent in the bmi case
it's not yet ready to be circulated to
the court
but i want to give you as much time
as i can to answer it
as we were into june already and the
clock was
running out
so i took this strat
on the plane with me to albany i was
going to the second circuit judicial
conference in lake george
reading it absolutely ruined my weekend
but i was
grateful that he gave me
the extra time
to respond and i think my
opinion in the bmi case is ever so much
stronger
because i had the benefit of justice
scalia's criticism
one quick footnote i i called that case
frontiero by accident that was an
earlier case so the vmi case which is
officially entitled united states versus
virginia
uh
is the case in which she pulled it all
together and
she was down there
last month couple months ago
to celebrate the anniversary of that
decision at vmi and there was a crowd
even bigger than this
and up in the
up there
a huge
group of people in identical uniforms
the vmi cadets
who gave her a standing ovation so
and there were women up there among them
and now i have a photograph of my
chambers
of
the women cadets
that behind bmi who are doing very well
and the school is
is
and now now realizes it made a very wise
decision
well here uh now from the audience some
questions we have a hard stop at 5 15.
[Laughter]
i knew this was going to happen
this is great
well
thank you
if you could
if you ask
ask your ask your question please be
brief uh
this is just for the georgetown
community questions from the georgetown
uh community
tell us uh
your name and uh what year you're in
i'm allie ross class of 2020 this is the
best moment of my life right now
my question is just for all the young
women in this room what do you see as
some of the biggest challenges they'll
face and what advice would you give them
if you were going to sit down with them
challenges
well for you
the challenges in
is
more daunting than the ones
that we faced i spoke before about there
being explicit
gender lines in the law so women can't
be
firefighters can't be
police officers it can't be
pilots or planes
those doors are now open to you
but what's left is
is what is called unconscious bias
my
best illustration of that is a symphony
orchestra when i grew up
you never saw a woman
in the orchestra
and the music critics thought that they
could tell the difference between a
woman playing the violin
and a man
same for other instruments
one day someone came up with the
brilliant idea let's drop a curtain so
that people who are doing the testing
don't see the people who are auditioning
and with that simple device
the drop curtain
women began to show up
in symphony orchestras
in numbers
sadly we can't
repeat that
in every
every area
my favorite decision in that line from
the 70s
was
of a title vii that's our principle
anti-discrimination law
title vii case against a t and t
for
not promoting women into middle
management jobs the women did great on
all the standard
criteria
but they flunked
the last test the total person test
which was an interviewer
interviewing the candidate for promotion
it wasn't a deliberate attempt
to screen out women
but the interviewer had a certain
comfort level facing someone who looked
like
himself
if he were confronting a member of a
minority group or a woman there was a
strangeness
he felt uneasy
it's getting over that unconscious bias
that remains a problem
together with the what's called the work
life balance
how do you arrange
work so that people can have a family
life
as well as a work life i think those are
the
the two biggest hurdles
my advice
is find out lies among
men as well as women
who want to change things
and think of yourself as bob said i did
as a teacher so don't react in anger
because that's going to be
counterproductive
if you call someone a sexist pig you've
turned him off
so
people asked was it difficult arguing
before the supreme court in those early
70s
i said i felt more like a kindergarten
teacher than anyone else
because there was
knowledge that i had that they didn't
have and i had to try to communicate
in a way that they would find appealing
uh justice ginsburg thank you so much it
was an honor to hear you speak today um
my name is donna artuzi and i'm a grad
student in the school of foreign service
focusing on security
and i'm wondering as someone who's
interested in hopefully joining the
legal profession at some point
hopefully both men and women can make
equal contributions in all areas of law
but are there areas in which you think
that women
maybe should become more involved or do
you think would be able to make more of
an impact at this time and hopefully
going forward
women can excel in
in
any area of the law
that interests them if they're willing
to put in the hours of work
that it takes to become
expert in one area
or
or another so i
with no doors being closed i think women
should choose what they feel
is there
and
that they are best equipped
to do
would you like to add to that
um
in a way
there are
areas in the law maybe you're referring
to this or asking this question
that are still predominantly male by
practice
yes thank you for rephrasing yeah
and and
i am sure there are
but
remarkably the the general trend has
been to include women everywhere
and it's
much much is owed to ruth ginsburg for
that of course
uh but
the the law also requires
now of course
that
you not be discriminated against on the
basis of your sex so we can hope to see
men doing legal jobs that perhaps were
thought to be
reserved for women like estates or
something like that back in the day
and that you could be
a lawyer
doing security
work for the united states right
and and one
extra postscript which is really
something justice ginsberg speaks about
a lot is that no matter what area you go
into
and it's also a georgetown tradition
if you do try to give back somehow to
either changing the law to make the
world a better place for others or
tutoring someone um there are all sorts
of ways to do it public interest work
pro bono work and that's something the
justice often speaks about that it's a
profession and we are privileged to be
in it so in a sense we owe a debt back
to society to carry on
that tradition
and i
would like to say that the honorable
robert katzman has
been a great leader in that regard he
saw a crying need for people in the
falls of the
immigration
system
needing
lawyers to represent them
and he really made it
happen with this
project that is now going forward
in
in new york you have how many how many
lawyers are we have the immigrant
justice corps
in the field has
78 fellows
in two and a half years
it has served
it has served over 28 000 immigrants and
their families
if you look at our
and our fellows
it turns out that most of them are women
a lot of them are
first generation
americans
proud to say that georgetown law center
is well represented in terms of the
fellows of the immigrant
justice corps
and
if you're interested as college students
uh when you graduate there is something
called the community fellows program
for college graduates who can who can
work in community-based
organizations
a large
part of the problem is that immigrants
live in fear
and
[Music]
you can really do something substantial
if you
try to
make their lives
easier
by giving them a sense that the american
dream can be their dream too
and the the commitment for the fellows
is what is it it's two years it's a
two-year guaranteed fellowship
uh with a with a prospect of a of a
third year
um
and the fellows are are
trained uh
in in a boot camp uh they they then get
to work with uh non-profit uh
organizations
uh a number of the organizations happen
to be organizations that that deal with
problems of of of women
and
and and children
we have a the immigrant justice corps
has had a rapid response team in texas
that has helped over a thousand women
and their children
so it's
remaking the immigration bar and uh
providing a whole new generation of
of leaders it's been a real inspiration
to to work with these people and and
thank you for well it is a sterling
example of
seeing a need there was nothing bob had
nothing when it began
and now it has this flourishing fellows
fellows program i'd like to mention
another effort
to do what
my dear colleague justice suter called
doing something outside yourself if
you're a true professional so justice
o'connor saw
a need for children to learn about the
government
most elementary school students didn't
you ask
what are the three branches of
government they couldn't tell you
so she started this i civics program
pitched to middle school
children
it's
now been introduced in schools across
the country but that idea of
seeing a need
knowing that you have
a talent that can help
respond to the need
oh my god i'm so excited
we are too
i'm oliver a sophomore from school
foreign service uh i have two questions
the first one is in the comments you
have one question okay
[Laughter]
in the context of
gender-based classifications do you
think it is necessary to improve it from
the intermediate obscurity to the strict
scrutiny uh will you do that
do i think it's necessary
to have levels of scrutiny
because i think
um when we deal with racism we will use
this districts scrutiny so i think we
also need to deal with sexism
there is a need to look with special
suspicion
that any law that disadvantages
a group of people
and especially when those people
are not
proportionately represented in
in legislative decision making or
executive decision making
so
yes i do think that there is a need to
give heightened scrutiny to laws
that disadvantage
any class of people
this we have time for one last question
wow
[Laughter]
my name is john greenberg i'm a student
of chemistry of college so and um i was
just wondering you've had an incredibly
impressive tenure on the court so i was
wondering what decision you were most
proud of and what
most disappointed you
that question
is like asking me which of my six
grandchildren am i
am i most proud of
all of them
i love my job
and every case
is important
so i
i couldn't single out any one case and
say
that's my favorite
i do think a case that has been
mentioned the bmi case
gave me great personal satisfaction even
the title of the case u.s against
virginia
when women first
aspired to become
leaders in the military
west point annapolis air force academy
didn't admit them so litigation was
started
in the 70s against the military
academies it was started by
women who thought they possessed the
necessary qualifications but were
excluded
by the time we get to
the bmi case it's no longer the women
seeking to get in although there were
many
who who didn't
seek admission to bmi it was the united
states government
telling the state of virginia the
government has an anti-discrimination
policy you can't exclude people simple
simply on the basis of their gender
whether that
whether it's excluding a male from a
nursing college in mississippi
or a woman from vmi so it was the united
states government saying that is the
policy of the united states
and virginia you better get on board so
then
wendy and mary were with me in february
when we were at bmi and it was most
exhilarating to see to meet and talk to
the women
cadets
we're going to be engineers nuclear
scientists
so i'm here that's that's one decision
of which i'm very proud i also
like the lilly ledbetter decision
because
i was on the losing side it was five to
four decision
but i thought that
my colleagues had
misinterpreted title vii
so
after describing what
lily's case was really about
my tagline was
the ball is now in congress's court to
correct the error into which my
colleagues have fallen
and in very short order
congress with
huge
majorities on both sides
past literally that better fair pay act
that adopted the
position that the defense the the
the
the the descent
took in that in that case
justice ginsburg it's been a
extraordinary honor
for all of us
uh
thank you for for being here
like to thank
uh wendy hartnett and and uh i mean mary
hartnett and wendy williams
um here's the book we can get a close-up
of the book
[Music]
[Applause]
i'd like also to thank georgetown
university president
jack the joya
professor charles king
chairman of the government department
for hosting this uh symposium i'd like
also to thank
aaron sharkey
aaron hudson
jeffrey
bible
mary haynes uh
for all of their their their support
andrea barrow
as noted in your programs
please exit gaston hall and head to the
campus ministry hallway on the first
floor
of this building
in order to receive a copy of your my
own words
make sure to
bring along the ticket located
in your program
thank you all for coming have a good
evening
[Applause]
oh
the white house corps